million questions for you guys but I
like throwing some curve balls at the
beginning if if someone has never seen
anything you've done before besides
Rebel Moon because obviously everyone
should watch Rebel moon what is the
first thing they should watch and
why oh um well I'm going to throw a
curveball right back and tell you that
this is the first movie I've ever done
wait a minute I just remembered that and
I'm so sorry but I knew that and uh yeah
I should have started with a different
question so I will give you the
exception and say rebel Moon okay yeah I
would
say I I'm so sorry I knew that kind of a
flex though like this is my first movie
you I mean no big deal or whatever bit a
flex I would say weirdly I don't know
since we're curve balling last man on
Earth just because no matter what genre
I do I just think it's important to know
I I think it's important for people to
know the comedy background that I
approach everything with
I think maybe it's good to know that no
I don't know I would say Zack sn's
Justice League B show show oh show
because it's one of the greatest comic
book movies of all time the director's
cut of that film is spectacular and i'
um with yeah I was going to go into a
tangent but it really is I love the
director's his his ver you know what I
mean absolutely um so making this for
making both these films was there what
was the night before you were shooting
something that you were actually in your
head about it in terms of like this is
going to be a really big day and I
really got to deliver and I'm not
sleeping yeah I have one I have one cuz
I joined a little later and my scene the
first time you see me I have quite a lot
to say and in the schedule I think you
guys hadn't shot much dialogue yet so it
was the first really big heavy dialogue
scene of the shoot and not only that it
was on a massive green green screen and
I had to emerge from my spaceship and
walk all the way across this massive
massive stage and hit a mark a black
mark on a black floor so I was just like
what the you know and it was like I
think four or five days we shot that it
was a it was a while yeah that was that
was a big sequence yeah and by the fifth
day I was like what what are words I
don't know but the night before I was a
bit like okay got to get all the lines
right uh for me I couldn't sleep cuz I
was just excited I was like man I can't
wait to get up and do this it's
going to be awesome oh wait I
can't can I say that on okay well bleep
it out cuz my mom's probably listen but
I was going to be like Hey listen this
is going to be awesome um and I you know
it's one of those things I can't sleep
because I'm I'm literally just like okay
I want to get up and go have fun with my
friends sure yeah yeah I think for me it
was the first big fight sequence that I
had to do um cuz I'd never had any
experience like that and I I generally
consider myself pretty gangly and
uncoordinated so
uh hopefully it looks good to the
viewers one of the things that's really
cool about this is that it's really hard
to make big budget original Ip and I
really give Zach and Netflix a lot of
credit for for making something like
this and it's a two-part movie so can
you sort of talk about being part of
something like this that isn't based on
you know other IP well it's great you
get to originate something right and how
often does that happen these days
especially something that's going to be
as big as what this universe is going to
be I mean Rebel moon is already we're
already expanding into the comics uh as
well they have House of the blood a a
prequel comic that's going to accompany
the film I think a couple weeks after in
January and it's it's massive like it it
does with all the work that I've done
this feels like it is the most humbling
because it's a very fresh beginning sure
yeah it's super rare I think to have a
completely original Ip it's really
really exciting and like to sit there
with Zach and have him just tell you the
whole movie off the top of his head
because it's all just swimming around in
there it's just like a really exciting
opportunity that doesn't come around
very often yeah yeah it's just exciting
to be a part of and and to be helping
someone like Zach realize this vision is
just like a true honor yeah so I'm
curious what is something in both part
one and part two that you are incredibly
excited for audiences to see well we
can't tell you about part two surprised
how how much people they're probably
they're probably going to edit that out
you know it's not spoiler it's not like
someone saying well this character you
know does it's more generalization but
you know what I mean yeah well uh I'm
just excited for people to get to know
deah more I think there's a there's a
lot more to come yeah I think the part
one is definitely the team building and
I think what I think folks are going to
really enjoy in part two is the sort of
expansion of that right we get a more
in-depth look at the characters that we
go to love in part one sure yeah yeah we
get to focus a little bit more on on on
single world in the second one and so I
think that viewers will be able to see
the detail that went into building that
world which is really exciting to see
one of the things listen I am a big fan
of Zack Snyder's director's cuts for me
that is like listen I'm super happy they
made the PG-13 I encourage everyone to
watch it but I know that the director's
cut for me is probably going to be the
one I rewatch again and again is there
anything that you can tease about the
longer cut that you are incredibly
excited for people to see I haven't seen
the Extended Cut just yet uh but
whatever it is I know it's going to be
awesome well it's all rated no it is it
is R-rated and that's one of the other
reasons why I am um you know I'm an
adult you know I'm looking forward to
seeing you know like for example Zach
said to me that the Cantina scene in the
PG-13 is the Cantina scene and in the
R-rated one it's the brothel scene MH
yeah see what I mean yes yeah there
definitely some interesting alts uh in
the filming of it all um that you'll be
able to see in the extended version but
uh at the end of the day it's that
interesting mix of like there's a world
in which all of these things can exist
at the same time and I think they're
they're doing something really
interesting and something that probably
will change how movies get made uh
because when folks watch this and they
love it and they watch the extended
version and they love that you know uh
all the streamers may end up going hey
look we need we need multiple rated
versions of of these things how do we
make that happen uh one of the things
I'll switch to something else one of the
things so I don't get you guys in
trouble this was a long shoot this is
153 day shoot and I'm curious as actors
what is it like when you're filming
something like this with essentially a
marathon because you can't really like
you know what I mean like it's you
really got to be prepared for such a
long period of time so as performers
what is that actually like and how are
you mentally and physically keeping
yourself together for such a shoot I
think I think in some ways the gym
helped um having that sense of routine
and and place for us to go and um all be
together kept a sense of like normaly or
like consistency around it and then just
like all the boring stuff like making
sure you sleep and and eat and call your
mom
and yeah yeah mean I don't know how
Sophia did it I mean she she runs on a
completely different level of energy
than anybody I've ever SE well she and
Zach both run on completely different
levels of energy than than people I've
ever seen um but those are the folks who
really help to keep you grounded and to
make sure that every body's everybody's
feeling good right that sort of thing
because you know the rest of us we we
may not be on set every day right we may
get a couple days off or maybe a week
off between certain things but she was
in it like full on almost the entire
time and so was Zach sure I well I was
in and out so I don't know if that's
easier or harder but like I was like at
home I think there were times when I had
like a month or two or you know at home
and having to just stay stay ready and
then come back and like be consist
yeah but that's the other thing is that
they could call you tomorrow and be like
we need you for a half day and mentally
being ready for that yeah you got to
stay ready to stay ready all year I know
I got to wrap but just real quick I am
very curious about Malcolm Washington's
the piano lesson so what can you tease I
can tease uh it's going to be great uh I
can tease I had a beautiful experience
on that and actually funny enough uh
both Malcolm and Zach had come to see a
play that I had done in La this past
summer and I got to introduce them to
each other so I said it was a peak
experience having two of the best film
director experiences I've had converge
in one place I said you know
everything's coming full circle on that
note I really do hope it's a huge hit
for you guys and wish you nothing but
the best and and stay healthy thank you
thank
you